so are we living in a video game
are we actually part of a giant
simulation I don't think you can no I
think you can argue that whoever is
written the simulation whatever super
entity is written a simulation could
make it so sophisticated that even your
memories our result of this of being
programmed by the simulate tour or
simulate tricks so the question is at
some level irrelevant but another level
I think we would have to agree it's
unknowable you can just presume any
level of sophistication that makes it
undetectable to us with that said there
have been a lot of science-fiction
stories where people discover that
they're living in a dome or inside a
hollow world or underground and the
metaphors for this are from our everyday
experience you hear about kids who've
been kidnapped and kept in a room till
they're 14 and they know nothing of the
world outside then the human mind
apparently at some level is uncapable of
detecting that outside world unless
something goes wrong for me as a
philosopher to prove that we were living
in a video game is an extraordinary
level of effort but if you can do it
bring it on but seems to me it's a hard
question to resolve because it's easy to
imagine a game designer a simulation
designer making it so sophisticated that
you can't tell good luck out there
you